[Music]
maybe you want to open the conversation
with inquiring about pronoun with
kindness and love I think there's
nothing more frustrating than someone
just seeing you as some of your gender
you would address a trans person like
you would address any other person you
would treat them as a person you just
say hi
start with that everybody has their own
nuanced definition of what transness
means to them it's basically identifying
as agenda value and not assigned being
born in the gender that I really just
don't feel comfortable in if you're
gonna give it a name strength i believe
that us transgendered women we have a
strength unlike any other
a trans person looks like any other type
of person that's like asking what does a
man look like or what does a woman look
like or what does a child look like
there's so many variables trans people
come in all genders or colors and also
you may you don't need to have
transitions to be transgender who trans
people are necessarily always visible
everybody's got a certain look there's
no particular uniform just like all sis
women don't look alike all trans women
don't look alike I mean look at you or
not honey I don't think we shared a
little mocha my transition was an
evolution I knew from an early age that
I felt something I didn't have the
language to articulate it I think
there's always been an element of me
that always knew I
at 19 that was possible transition and
in transition till 35 but you said
everyone's journey is completely
different I mean I always knew I was
attracted to feminine things when I was
around five but my parents didn't know I
didn't even know the term Jones or
transgender I was just told no you
shouldn't be into Barbies you should be
as a GI Joe I was in something open
not all transgender people are
heterosexual and neither are they on gay
gender and sexuality are not the same
thing
I've always been about beauty doesn't
have a sex for me so at the end of the
day it's like what I'm gonna remember is
whether or not you're a nice person not
all trans people take hormones or decide
to take hormones I might give it to me
baby
I love my moans a year into my
recognition to myself I was just like
this is everything that I've always
known but brought it together like it
brought my levels and everything
together so in a sense it brought me
right for my blood ties some trans
people choose to use hormones because
they want to have masculinizing
characteristics added to their body or
they want to have feminizing
characteristics in their body and they
don't naturally produce those being
trans does not require having surgery so
you kind of are like forced like okay I
need to have all these surgeries so I
can blend in and people can accept me
but really I didn't have to have any
other surgery because I just needed to
love myself and be accepted everyone's
journey is completely different I mean
think that how you feel inside is
exactly that and if you feel like you've
got to do something to make that inside
feel right than you do it's all about
the process of changing your body if you
want to to make yourself feel more
comfortable and peaceful within your own
mind you can be trans and never have any
type of surgery never do anything at all
maybe just change your name change your
pronouns you can do whatever you can
self-define
dating wall traffic is a nightmare it's
so annoying I mean that it's not like
there's not people out there it's just a
minefield either extreme fetishism or
extreme rejection there's really no
middle ground from assertive woman is
very different than being a touchy-feely
guy now I'm a creep so I had to like
learn all of those kind of nuanced
behavior patterns a lot of guys that
approach me assume that I am cysts so do
I tell him immediately do I tell him via
text do I call him do we meet up at
Starbucks it's so much that runs through
my mind as far as okay this man is
feeling me how am I going to deliver
this news to him it's scary because
you're going to a situation where
someone doesn't necessarily know your
background and I don't fear for myself
necessarily but for transwomen that's a
very dangerous situation to be in you
know women do get killed
my first thought is were not accepted by
society that is a very good question why
did black people get murdered why does
anyone out there coming outside of their
face crooked taking someone else's life
because of whatever it is that they're
going through trans women of color are
being murdered left and right and
they're not getting the same opportunity
as assessed person or is this white
person the reality of the matter is a
lot of the murders are based in stigma
and shame there's a lot of fear in who
does this person make me and what does
it say about my masculinity and who I am
in front of everybody else there's so
many reasons why trans women are
murdered but ultimately it comes down to
prejudice it comes to inequality and it
comes to lack of understanding about
trans people and the member find us
attractive of course he can be religious
I identify and believe in Buddhism and I
have practiced that since I was a child
religions meant to be for everybody
anybody can be religious anybody can be
religious transitioning was like a
spiritual experience for me I finally
felt like I was my whole self and as a
result I found a relationship with a
higher power of my understanding
[Music]
the way that my mind is formed has been
a blessing and that's a lot of that is
down to being trans and empathizing and
coming into contact with so many amazing
people that I don't know if I would have
met if I was sitting able to look at
yourself and because you have to a lot
of times you're like why am i why am i
different what is wrong with me and so
you spend a lot of time thinking about
who you are I love being trans having a
human experience and I got to be both
sexes at the end of the day when none of
us are worth anything if we don't love
ourselves that has everything with how
it is that you hold your head up and how
proud you are the thing I love most
about being trans is getting this
complete 360-degree view of what it
means to be a human being but what I
love most about being trans for myself
it's just been my journey throughout
womanhood and sharing stories with
fellow trans women and even cysts women
seeing differences and similarities I
love that people are googling these
questions because that means you're
curious and you want to learn something
about the trans community you can find
out more than you ever will on Google I
swear I actually speaking to people
[Music]